you know make it quick the schedule
today is very exciting two talks in the
morning both very machine learning
focused long lunch like always and then
a bunch of shorts and our first because
this morning is our teasing from she
learning to ferment at Carnegie Mellon
she's going to tell us about active
simply thank you
well thanks for dog to the organizers
for inviting me it seems like it's been
a great workshop so far and I wish I
could have joined earlier but I will be
around at least for most of today and
I've been watching some of the talks
actually just at least to in brief so
the nice thing is these are all streamed
and so we can I guess have access to
those so I talked about active sampling
in the context of unsupervised learning
in particular so let me start with sort
of the big level high level picture
which is this works okay so everybody's
talking about big data that there's lots
and lots of data out there and you know
we have no dearth of data so to speak
and not so much caring about what data
do we collect right and I guess a lot of
this workshop has been focused on
interactive learning what can we learn
with interactions why do we have to be
careful by do why can't we just keep on
collecting data arbitrarily why do we
have to be judicious maybe about what
data we collect what type of
interactions we do and I mean the
motivation is clear that the systems
that we are trying to understand our
even bigger no matter how much data we
have think of computer network no matter
no matter how much you know we are
collecting gigabytes terabytes petabytes
of data but it's still not enough to
measure the round-trip time let's say
between any pairs of nodes in the
internet right and we'll never have
access to that item type of data
similarly people are building fancy
things like the optic cameras which are
recording not just the intensity of
value at a single pixel but also
properties of the material right there
you're recording spectral
characteristics they are recording their
angular characteristics like lots of
different things that you basically can
point the camera at something and it'll
tell you what is the composition of the
material there so they are recording so
many different things about it but again
in theory you can correct everything but
when it comes down to practice you have
to get it down to a small device and so
you can't
really measure all of the interesting
properties that you might be interested
in I think of smart cities we have again
we are equipping our buildings with lots
and lots of sensors collecting lots of
streaming data but again that data is
never enough you can't monitor you know
things in every room or every part of a
building and it's just we always have to
make decisions about where do we put the
sensors what type of data the video we
collect and again I have to don't have
to do it for every application but you
get the idea so when we have a limit on
how much data we can collect what can we
do if you only have partially observed
data and I want to categorize into these
two or actually I should say really
three so I'll talk about passive
sampling which is data either drawn
uniformly at random which means you just
randomly choose from the data here is
just like a data matrix or it could be
read a tensor but you just choose
randomly the entries that you are
observing in this matrix another thing
that I categorize under passive sampling
is the ability to select data which
entries you want to observe but prior to
seeing any other data so this is what
statistics literature typically refers
to as experimental design you're talking
about can a design which measurements I
want to obtain but using other
information I have but not measurements
from the system so I'll give an example
of that as well so for example you can
think of you are given a graph and just
knowing the graph you want to decide
which location so this could be a road
network you want to decide which
locations you want to sense sample you
know something about that the
measurements are smooth on this graph
for example right so you can decide the
measurements you can decide them
uniformly at random or you can decide to
pick these measurements based on the
structure of the graph but it's still
not active sampling which is what I'll
get to in a minute which is really
feedback driven you observe some data
and based on that you decide where the
sample next okay so both data drawn
that's drawn uniformly at random or
selected prior to observing any data I
call both of these as passive sampling
and then active sampling is going to be
where we selectively draw data in a
feedback driven way which could be in a
streaming manner it could be in a batch
manner where you observe some batch and
based on that you decide where
next and this is relevant in many
applications where we have control over
what data to acquire so we can be
interactive with the measurement
generation process so in learning say
round-trip times between different
computers on the internet we are sent
sending packets to measure these
round-trip times so we can be selective
about which nodes we do the pynx or
trace routes to in biological context we
can be selective about which experiments
we do which drug gene interactions to be
observed and even in a camera right plan
optic camera we can be particular about
which properties do we want to measure
and store all right so at a high level
you would like to understand what are
the fundamental trade-offs between a lot
of the resources we have access to so I
refer to these two different axes as the
statistical efficiency axis where you
are measuring some performance of your
system in terms of some error so it
could be a risk you know your noise
tolerance or error miss clustering error
miss classification error mean square
error in regression things like this are
noise tolerance they'll all be along the
statistical efficiency axis measurement
efficiency is how many data points do we
need okay so that's the measurement
aspect you can also think about
communication computation memory and one
other one that's often not thought about
as much as model assumptions so I'll put
another axis here it's in a slightly
different spirit than the rest but this
is model assumptions what kind of model
assumptions do we need to get a
particular trade-off let's say between
statistical and measurement accuracy
which is easier to access that people
care about the most
or have cared about the most so far of
course now people are starting to think
about some of these other axes as well
at least like in statistical learning
literature and a lot of the active
learning work has also focused on how
can we improve this trade-off between
statistical and measurement efficiency
by being by using feedback being clever
about what measurements we are obtaining
and I will talk about how active
sampling can enhance many trade-off
between many of these things so in some
cases I only focus on statistical and
measurement efficiency sort of like the
classical problem
in other cases I'll point out where it
also leads to either computational gains
gains in terms of the model assumptions
you might be making and so on all right
so let me start with how do we think of
the power of active learning so active
learning has mostly been thought of in
the supervised context where you're
deciding whether or not to obtain the
label of a data point right so this is
the I think most of the work is on
classification which basically just
talks about you have discrete labels
many times use binary labels and you are
deciding given a point or a pool of
points or you can synthesize points do
you want to collect the corresponding
label or not and can I decide which
points I get a label for you know
feedback driven runner
and I want to point out that in some
sense at a higher level we can think of
the power of active sampling bean
whenever there is some heterogeneity in
the problem then active methods can
learn about that heterogeneity using
feedback and they can focus on the
sampling to learn better okay but sort
of this heterogeneity is important and
not only does the system have to have
some heterogeneity which I will give
many examples of but it also has to be
unknown so going back to my graph
problem if I tell you the graph right so
I talked about the problem where we have
to learn the graph then I will show
after sampling helps but if I tell you
the graph and your function is smooth on
it this is actually something I didn't
include in the talk but maybe I can talk
during the afternoon if there's still
spots or if you have some time but in
that case you can show that you know the
graph so you already know the
heterogeneity
you can't experimental design your
observations but using feedback you
don't gain anything so I just want you
to sort of make that point that somehow
the heterogeneity has to be unknown we
have to be able to learn it from data
that's when active sampling is going to
help and in classification what's the
heterogeneity it's the fact that points
in the other decision boundary are more
important right so if you think of what
has been shown in this context what
people have shown including many people
in this audience Rob Steve Nina lots of
other people have chai here all right
have talked about improvements and
classification settings
in a 1d simple problem so you have a
single feature the rates for passive
learning they depend on how quickly do
the labels go from being one to zero
right so this is just the probability of
label wean one give an X and of course
zero being given X is just the
complement of that right one minus that
and so the more quickly this function
changes near the decision boundary of
half the in binary classification the
rate is affected by that and in the
active context what people have shown is
if you are selective about where you are
making collecting the labels for watched
data points you can focus collection of
data points near the decision boundary
and you will actually get an improvement
in your rate like this so instead of 2
kappa -1 here you get a two-carbon -2
which is an improved rate
similarly for regression problems which
are slightly less started now if you
think about regression in the standard
context people usually assume your
regression function as smooth if your
regression function is smooth there's
not too much to be learnt by feedback
driven sampling because everything is
nice and well-behaved there's no
heterogeneity in the system but as Rob
and Rui and Rebecca and some other
people had worked on if you have
piecewise smooth functions so you have
functions that might look like this in
2d let's say a bit simple piecewise
constant functions or piecewise smooth
functions then you have different
smoothness and different regions and
active sampling can precisely focus on
these regions and giving you an improved
rate compared to passive so going by
this idea now I wanted to talk about
unsupervised problems
what kind of heterogeneity is might
exist and how we can exploit those using
active sampling so I'll talk about three
problems the first one is learning the
structure of graphical models and in
this context the heterogeneity will come
in because our graphical model so it's
going to be based on a graph I'll define
it formally but essentially we can say
that the different nodes have different
degrees so if we different nodes have
different degrees that's the
heterogeneity in our problem and active
sampling can exploit that similarly
another problem I'll talk about is
matrix or tensor completion or
approximation or
problem is column subset selection I'll
mention some results along this
direction the heterogeneity here again
comes from the fact that so a lot of
time people have done these problems
they assume the matrix is like low rank
you are trying to recover it from
partially observed data but they assume
that all the columns are rows have the
energy well spread out amongst all the
coordinates but you are if you have
certain spiky columns or rows that's
exactly when at the again have
heterogeneity in your problem an active
sampling can focus on those and yield
improvements another is hierarchical
clustering and I think friends will
talked about some improvements in the
clustering context earlier in the week
and what I'll talk asan or I briefly
mentioned was also on I don't think I'll
have too much time to get into it is
heretical clustering where you have
multi scale clusters so there are some
larger clusters and within those there
is further grouping that leads to
smaller clusters and smaller clusters
and the heterogeneity naturally comes
from that that the fact that you have
multi resolution clusters so again
active sampling can focus on that all
right so with that sort of high-level
picture I'll start with the first
application which is of graphical model
structure learning so the problem is as
following we want to learn conditional
independence relations between variables
using few samples from them so the
variables of interest could be the
readings at different sensors and we are
interested in learning the conditional
dependency graph between all these
sensors so which sensors measurements
are dependent on which other ones
condition longer meaning and we want to
be able to learn this graph so it's an
unknown graph from few observations at
each node that's one motivation you
could similarly think of trying to learn
a protein interaction Network where you
are interested in learning the
conditional independence relations
between different protein or gene
expressions and you again want to take
few measurements from each protein or
gene and there are other applications as
well so formally sleep speaking
graphical models essentially encode this
notion that I and J two variables don't
have an edge if X I is independent of XJ
given all the rest of the variables so
that's just what defines
a graphical model its encoding all the
conditional independence relations to
nodes are independent given everything
else and in particular let's talk about
a very simple setting of Gaussian
graphical models so we have a result for
a matter matter active learning
algorithm for any graphical model but at
least in this case it's computationally
efficient so let's talk about the
setting where you have P variables and
they are just distributed jointly
according to a big Gaussian distribution
with zero mean and some covariance
matrix Sigma so in this case it turns
out that such conditional independence
relations imply that if we look at Sigma
inverse the inverse of the covariance
matrix then it has zeros wherever there
is an absence of an edge meaning that if
I have one entry if I have the IJ entry
in Sigma inverse equal to zero then I
and J are independent given everything
else so here's an example of a graphical
model and you can see that for example
x1 is only connected to x2 not 2 3 4 and
5 and so these 3 entries are 0 and
similarly so on so in this case people
have recently started how many samples
do you need to be able to learn this
graph so again the graph is between
these P variables right so X 1 through X
P these P variables and how many samples
do we need from these variables to be
able to learn it rather and first there
are lower bounds which say that the
number of samples we are collecting n
samples from each of the P variables so
I will say it's a total of NP scalar
samples and that needs to scale like the
maximum degree of that graph times P log
P ok but it can be done
actually efficiently this is just a
lower bound so it says you need at least
that many examples to learn it from
passive samples
and there is a corresponding matching
upper-bound we're using a very simple
algorithm which is basically node wise
law so you take the measurements at
every of every variable you regress it
on to the N samples from other variables
using lasso you put an l1 penalty and
wherever there's a 0 you don't have an
edge and you have an edge whenever the
coefficients regression coefficients are
nonzero and it has been shown that in
that case that simple algorithm is able
to achieve this lower bound and the
total number of scalar samples you need
is the maximum degree times P log P for
this algorithm under the Gaussian
graphical model sorry so if you think a
little bit more about passive sampling
and what it requires it requires that
you have n samples from all of the
variables from this big joint
distribution and we are talking
large-scale right so P is large that
comes from this joint distribution right
now in any application if you think
about for example the sensor application
or this gene gene or protein protein
interaction network collecting such
measurements is very expensive right
because you are talking about well 1
being able to synchronize all the
sensors so to obtain one sample from
every node we are saying you're sampling
from this big Joint Distribution you
need n samples from all of them sort of
one sample has to be sampled from the
Joint Distribution so there is a cost of
synchronization and of course also cost
of measurement you are requiring that
you get expression levels of all genes
or all proteins under a particular let's
say drug right which might also be
expensive so you in practice you have
limitations that may not allow you to do
the synchronization or do the
measurements of all the variables
together so in that context we can talk
about active sampling and here's a
better framework that we can use so we
can say that we are going to select a
subset of these P variables at every
round and we are going to obtain some NL
samples from each one of those variables
alright and we just keep doing this
round every round so we start we start
with some subset and we collect some
number of measurements from them and
then we discard some of them which we
think we are learn their neighborhoods
and then we keep focusing our samples
the harder and harder variables that are
that have more complex dependency
structures and we collect more samples
from them and we keep on repeating this
process Horning in on the more complex
one and how many total samples we need
so again comparing to the N times P for
passive sampling now if in every route
we are using n L samples from SL which
is our subset of variables you are
sampling from we need some of another
cell number of samples no no will picked
up yeah I'll tell how we pick them for
the passive face imply that you know if
you were to somehow passively sample
subsets at this time you need P times
because T times if you randomly sample
yeah it applies to so they construct a
hard-enough class for which you can't
that random subsampling wouldn't give
you anything you it still requires yes
although that graph would still require
ya degree max number of samples you
can't do this with random sampling that
it's a lower bound for all paths of
sampling
so how do we do this so it's a very
simple procedure we start why exactly as
I said we are going to take some samples
so we're going to take some samples from
all the nodes but very few samples so we
might be omits it's right not perfect in
the sense if you're practitioners you
will say I don't even want to have any
number of samples from all the variables
okay so we haven't solved that problem
I'm very interested in how we can solve
that but what you can do is you can take
some small number of samples from all
the variables and then you can try to
get an estimate of their neighborhoods
now some neighborhoods will be correct
and some will be wrong because for some
you won't have enough samples to learn
all the dependencies but for the ones
that are correct you can use half your
budget to do the learning of the
neighborhoods and half the budget to
verify that you have found the right
neighborhood and then you can stop
sampling from them that's the basic idea
okay so it's a very simple idea so the
algorithm proceeds as follows we take so
initialize L is just a counter we'll
initialize it to 1 and we'll collect
some constant times L log P samples P is
the number of variables in this from
everything that initially the XP /
Saturn's that is everything we haven't
settled or stopped sampling from so
initially it's everything and we take
that many samples use we are going to
use d1 for learning and same number of
samples for very verifying the
neighborhoods and then sequential e for
every node for the whose neighborhood we
haven't found we are going to learn
their neighborhood and verify their
neighborhood
so we'll just learn the neighborhood
using la so the only thing we need to be
careful about is that we enforce that
law so does not return or if it can
return a larger neighborhood but we
restrict it to l1 so what I ll whatever
is our current iteration size we
restrict the neighborhood to be of that
size it cannot return more than that
many non-zeroes we just take the top and
that's important to make sure that the
number of samples you have is enough to
do the testing the verification of the
neighborhood and then you verify the
neighborhood by basically saying now I
have learned some neighborhoods I'm
going to condition on these variables
that are in my neighborhood and I'll
check whether this variable is now
independent of all the other variables
once I condition on this lawn
neighborhood
and we do that just using the second
half of the samples and if the partial
correlation with all other neighborhoods
is small then you believe that you have
found the neighborhood of this node
otherwise you have not so there's one
more refinement to what are the meta
procedure that I had explained which is
if we found the net find the
neighborhood of a node we don't stop
sampling it immediately we actually have
to make sure we also have found its
neighbors neighborhoods because we need
its neighbors neighborhoods we are we
need it to find its neighbors
neighborhood okay so we have to start
right off keep Cal sampling until you
get the neighbor of that node and of its
neighbors but once that's done you add
it to your you stop sampling from that
node and now you just double your budget
which was so L is affecting your
sampling budget you double that and you
start again with the remaining nodes and
keep on doing this and you stop when you
have exhausted your budget or you found
the neighborhood of everything you
stopped several means you stopped
sampling exactly
Mars radiation just means I'm stop
sampling from these are measured from
the remaining right I just pick the
measurement from the remaining say a
hierarchical Bayesian approach to sample
from all the variables you sample from
some subset that you've learned
something about some of the others of
the other variables if there was some
underlying assumption associated with
the Gaussian prior matters some kind of
a Bayesian assumption but this is all as
I saying like the heterogeneity here
which is the neighborhoods we are trying
to discover are unknown so how would you
impose such a prior somehow to come up
with such a prior you would need
information about the varying degrees
right presumably some underlying true
Gaussian that you're trying to learn so
in the current case there could be some
some shared assumption the premise
I mean standard hierarchical Bayesian
assumptions where you don't need to know
everything okay maybe I'll find about
here what exactly have in mind but if
you have such other prior information
which is like the two nodes are related
in more than just what is given by the
graphical model the conditional
independence relations sure you can
bring that to bear but I'm happy to talk
more offline so you have some sort of
hub nodes present in the graph then that
last bit about neighbors neighbors being
included seems pretty bad because you
need more samples for the high degree
node to get learn but till all of its
neighbors also have to stay around so
actually yeah this can so first of all I
mean that's important point the whole
thing here is that yes you will collect
more samples from the hub nodes less
samples from other nodes but you are
pointing to that now all the neighbors
of the hub node will also you can't stop
sampling them it turns out you can I
think we can tighten the algorithm to do
that so yeah if you're thinking of a
star graph once you have learned you can
basically learn the neighborhoods of all
the remaining spokes and you can
guarantee that the algorithm will then
you would have already learned that
neighbors of the hub guy and you will we
can stop sampling so it's just not
coming out in this but the other
algorithm will naturally do that so this
basically it depends on what is the
smallest entry in your inverse
covariance matrix and even like passive
algorithms assume that that's lower
bounded from below if it can be
arbitrarily small then of course yeah
you're in trouble with both parts of an
octave you could though I don't think
I've seen that even for the passive case
algorithms like that they just but
you're right I mean if that quantity
itself could be arbitrarily small right
the smallest entry that's also a
heterogeneity in your system you can
adapt to it right you're absolutely
right that's the way at least I think of
it that you are you that you're
conditioning could be bad like there are
so many things you are holding constant
here which could be bad but once you say
that they are bad means that now you can
adapt to it right yeah that's a good
point
all right so what do we gain by doing
this procedure now we can show that the
number of active samples that you that
are sufficient to recover such a
faithful version grafica so all the
assumptions are the same here D max J
I'm going to indicate as the it's not
the maximum so earlier we had the
maximum degree of the graph now I have
the maximum degree of any neighbor of
the of G H node so this is a very local
quantity it could almost be the degree
of that node except we also have to
sample it for its neighbor so I think
this might you might actually be able to
improve this to just the degree of the
node but right now it's the maximum
degree for every node it's the maximum
degree of its neighbors and so basically
you can show that the total number of
scalar samples you need now scales like
the sum of all these local degrees times
log P versus being the maximum degree
times P log P or another way to think of
this is how many samples where am i
correcting per node on average
instead of d-max logs you know I'm
collecting the average log be roughly
speaking so it's like it scales like the
average degree all you have made the
number of samples needed per node
adaptive to its local degree if it's
easy if it's independent node you can
like very few samples if it's connected
to only one other node or again you're
collecting few samples but if it's
connected to a lot of nodes then you are
paying a price for that corresponding
right so yeah one is that you get sort
of this average of the local max degrees
instead of the global max degree so it's
better for skew degree distributions
which is almost always the case you
never have uniform graphs in practice
and it also minimizes the need for
synchronization at least to some extent
that you only need synchronization in
the very initial stage for a few samples
of course the question of can we do this
without requiring synchronization of all
the nodes
even once is open I don't know how to
solve that
so you've done simulations and egg that
those are exactly the cases you see
improvement for power-law graphs and so
on but I don't have a quantification of
it yeah that's a good question you could
try to quantify it in that context so
there is okay I almost shouldn't say
there is a paper on archives let me say
it this way we just show a lower bound
it just came up out recently it has it I
think it should what it shows is that
you get DJ naught D max J which we don't
know on one hand it seems like yes you
probably can adapt to the local degree
but because I mean hug like context you
can sort of do it seems natural to do
that but I don't know if it can you can
completely close the gap between these
two in general yeah we thought about
this for a while haven't been able to
close that gap so so just for the lower
bound instance types used in passive so
it's can I is the lower bounds I said I
can give it sort of an arbitrary degree
distribution and still it will force our
dependence on D Max or is it using a
very specific type of
distribution to construct a lower
balanced and very passive I'm just
wondering does their lower bound
instance actually have a lot of
heterogeneity in the degrees and you say
it has heterogeneity it's but it's it's
heterogeneity in the sense of I think
they consider like CLE courses nodes
that are independent kind of things so
there is heterogeneity yes
that's what Alec had asked about so yes
if it's a star graph right now it says
that yeah it's no worse no better than
random some or passive sampling but the
algorithm will actually like in that
case once you discover the neighborhoods
of all the spokes right you can settle
the hub also because you have discovered
its neighborhood right but in general so
I think of this is on a larger scale
where you might have multiple hubs and
there are lots of graphs that have yes
the hubs are connected to a lot of
things but then there are lot of other
nodes as well related not to different
maps it can be D max I mean for this
sauerkraut for instance it can be better
okay but I'm saying that I think this
can also be improved for the star graph
for start-up in fact this would just be
the degree of the I mean it will just be
the degree of that actually won't be the
degree it will be just one I mean the
degree will correspond to just the
spokes
it won't correspond to the hub in
general so in terms like the algorithm
will do that but the bounce right now
sort of because you were saying you
don't know when that happens you don't
know where to stop right has this
behavior but for a given budget if you
compare passive and active you will see
that the improvement there
all right so yeah actually if there are
more questions we can talk about those
because otherwise I was going to move on
to another problem I also could somebody
keep track of time
oh yeah I can stop whenever needed
absolutely so right now we have in fact
I mentioned that plus incurrence
understood eigenvalue conditions they
are exactly the same as for the passive
case both of them are holding these as
constants if these can be yeah you okay
no law heterogeneity in it that they
could be different for different nodes
right or different yeah subsets of nodes
could be different in terms of threw
strictly eigenvalue you can add up to
that also potentially yeah I can say
more offline okay so now I wanted to
move to this problem of matrix are they
I guess I will mostly talk about matrix
completion the same results can be
extended to tensor completion as well
and what we can do with active sampling
so here the goal is we have a matrix
that we want our only given some entries
right and we want to be able to complete
this matrix and the active question will
be that those entries are not uniformly
sampled at random but we have control
over which entries to observe and again
this can happen if you're interested in
learning say round-trip times between
some hosts and clients right we have
control over which once we measure in a
computer network we have control over
the drug gene interruptions we measure
even the recommendation systems to some
extent not completely but like you can
choose which how to design your survey
basically or commodities to ask a user
to rate again not completely but in some
applications you can do that so if you
look at all the work on trying to do
this completion of this matrix they
assume that the matrix is slower on or
near low rank and I talked about when
you can do the reconstruction and one
thing that comes up is this incoherence
or level it's core notion so basically
the idea is if I have a matrix like this
all zeros green is all zero one non-zero
entry there's no hope you can't recover
it from partial
at all right partially observed data
very few entries in the matrix you need
to observe all the entries to be able to
find it
and so what the most of the papers are
all the papers on passive matrix
completion as you is that your matrix is
both row and column incoherent which
means that sort of if I look at well I
give a precise definition but
essentially the energy in your rows or
columns are uniformly kind of spread out
amongst all the entries okay and what I
will talk about is when active learning
buys an improvement is when you can have
this kind of a situation where it's
spread out but it's only needs to be
spread out in one direction only the
rows are the columns so they can be
spiky columns if you will I think I
mostly focus on yeah allowing the
columns to be spiky okay so formally
this definition of coherence is we are
looking at so U is going to be a
subspace in this case it's let's say the
column subspace or the row subspace and
we look at how aligned it is with any of
the canonical basis vectors so if I take
any single entry how much you know does
it the projection onto this column space
look like how spiky is it essentially
so you can have make anomalous genes and
anomalous right that you might want to
spend more sampling to learn more about
them whereas other genes who are
predictive of other genes you can you
know sample less from then that's the
idea
it's similarly in computer networks if
it's yeah these are nodes within a
subnet I think you did some work you can
sort of predict them from each other but
if they are in yeah you might at least
want to get sort of representative
samples from different uh so yes in some
application that can come up again we
mean we haven't like worked on one
specific application to show that but
it's motivated by that right so yeah I
just wanted to mention the connection to
elaborate score so basically this
quantity is precisely the unnormalized
leverage score of the eyuth coordinate
if the use of space is the subspace
spanned by the top k principal
components right so that's why these
notions are very related except they're
coherence you do the N by K up front
which where n is the dimension of the
matrix and K is the rank of the matrix
or at least the rank that you care about
approximating so in this case there are
lower bounds which show that the number
of random entries necessary to recover
an N by n matrix of rank or with row and
column space Cochrane's bounded by mu so
both of them have to be bounded energy
has to be well spread out they look like
mu R log n per column so I'm again going
to stated per column if you care about
the total complexity you can just
multiply it with it it's an N by n
matrix it's n mu R log n which is pretty
close to in some sense what you can
expect because there are n R degrees of
freedom if it's rank R matrix of size n
by n there are n R degrees of freedom
this is sort of the best you can hope to
do right so this only the Mew comes in
it's the natural notion as I send Musa
incoherence right that comes in and log
and it's just a small extra price you
can potentially hope to improve that
that's all there is and there is a
matching upper actually there are many
of matching upper bounds but here is one
of them they're optimal in different
contexts but the sales at the number of
random entry sufficient to recover such
a matrix which is precisely rank are n
by n with row and column space
confidence pounded by being scale like
mu R log square n per column and you can
achieve
using let's say nuclear Nam minimization
which is a convex formulation you're
saying find me the matrix that matches
my observed entries while having the
smallest rank here nuclear Nam is a
surrogate for convex surrogate for the
rank okay so what can after sampling
do in this case and what first what does
an active sampling algorithm look like
well we can say that we start in a
purely sequential manner and we draw
some number of entries from a column and
we check if it lies in the space spanned
by the previous columns we have observed
if it does we don't need to collect any
more entries we can just complete it
using the existing number of columns but
if it does not line the space then we
observe all its entries and we added to
this subspace candidate subspace V or
maintain it so that's the simple
algorithm you start with the first one
you don't have anything to project on to
so you observe everything right it
doesn't lie in the space spanned by
whatever you have you observe everything
for the next one you check whether it
lies in the space spanned by the first
one using again this this step requires
a test where you're testing or partially
observed vector using a fully observed
subspace right and Laura and Rob did
some work on saying when did this test
of succeeds you can show it succeeds
with what probability and those are
exactly the results we'll pour to this
setting to talk about how what is the
improvement you get in terms of actively
sampling this matrix so what is the
improvement well essentially what
happens is that our of the columns
because the matrix has rank or get fully
absorbed and all the remaining you just
observe some M entries which is your
initial budget that you have for every
column and as long as that initial
budget scales like mu R log square R
where the column space n Co hence is
bounded by mu we only need now the
column space in governs to be bounded
rows can row space does not have to be
in CONUS does not have to be bounded and
so your columns can be spiky so row
space cover and supplies columns can be
spiky and then the algorithm recovers
this matrix with high probability using
only
essentially yeah that enough to call our
of the columns are fully observed so n R
comes from that and n 2 columns have
entry
entries observe that's very good to end
to them right and plugging the
requirement on em we get you need to
sample and mu R log square R number of
entries and we can also talk about the
runtime so it runs in time which is
essentially if you think of it as an N
by n matrix its linear in M or sub
linear in the matrix size N squared so
in this case actually we can I just
chose a very simple example of exact
Laurent matrix just to show that you get
a bunch of different benefits by using
this active sampling algorithm one is
that in terms of measurement complexity
I mean again there wasn't too much to
squeeze out anyways because I told you a
low rank matrix of rank R which is n by
n has only n are degrees of freedom so
you see that all we do is get from mu R
log square and to MU R log square R
right so now I mean some people call it
an exponential improvement right because
you're getting from a constant to lower
right log n but yeah it may or may not
but I think the interesting thing is
that it's independent of the matrix size
so that's maybe one way to think about
it how many entries you need per column
does not scale as I add more you know
movies into your matrix or more yeah
drugs into your design sort of right
that's one way to think of it in terms
of computational complexity anything to
do with nuclear nor minimization or most
of the algorithms are about like you do
some singular value threshold Aang and
doing that requires and square R times
however many times you are doing that
some kind of repetitive SVD s so the
complexity scales N squared and this
algorithm because it's like doing it
just in a very purely sequential manner
its complexity is linear in n I think
that's the wrong point to observe linear
in n or sub linear in the matrix size N
squared and it actually runs very fast
so if you compare it to the singular
value threshold in algorithm on some
large matrices with rank let's a hundred
here instead of it can do it in five
minutes instead of two hours compared to
the passive
it also another thing is it's completely
sequentially processing the columns
instead of being non sequential right
which most other algorithms are you
require the entire partially observable
matrix up front even in terms of memory
complexity again I mean this can be
improved for passive I'm not saying that
this is you can't improve it for passive
in fact I think existing recent
algorithms are able to improve it but
this algorithm only requires NR because
you're only storing that subspace that
you're maintaining and that requires n
times our entries but I think the most
important part actually according to me
is none of these it's really the fact
that you have increased the class of
matrices you can handle and this goes
back to the model assumption thing I was
talking about right that you sample
complexity is sure a little bit improved
but you have improved the sample
complexity for a much larger class you
can you're allowing matrices that can
have spikes that's exactly what active
learning is buying you right in fact a
few yeah the example here so if you look
at here is an example of a matrix with
coherent rows which means spiky columns
then you see that this is the pattern
that the octave algorithm has it's
taking some random samples from most of
the columns it's only taking few samples
and then there are some columns from
which it takes observes them almost and
forth so it's focusing on these harder
examples if as a practitioner I know is
there a way to adapt to it yes you don't
know which one it is you can adapt to it
let's see
well one simple thing you can do is book
do it both ways but yeah can you do it I
mean yeah in terms of theory it'll work
out but there can probably be a better
practical algorithm that does it yeah
yeah the good question yeah you would
care about that so here's I'm just
showing the gap between value if you
actually design matrices that have
incoherent roles in aeration to columns
then you don't see any improvement but
you see an improvement when there are
coherent rows all right and in fact so
this was work done reduction was also
here and he also showed this lower bound
which says that the number of passive
entry is necessary to recover an N by n
matrix of rank R with only column space
Conference bounded by me where we don't
make any assumption on the row space in
governance is actually n per column so
you basically need to observe all the
entries in a column to be able to do
this using passive entries any kind of
passive entries again whether these are
somehow experimental in designed or
random any distribution after sampling
is necessary to handle coherent rows and
again going back to sort of again I want
to emphasize this idea again that if if
we look at the comparison I mentioned
earlier was actually in some sense
unfair to active sampling because for
incoherent matrices you get a slight
improvement but really this is the way
to look at it that for Rho coherent
matrices random sampling would require n
per column but we require only mu our
logs where our per column so that's
you're getting a big gain over a larger
class how much time to have or none use
not about 45 minutes so far okay so I
can I guess what I can do is quickly
summarize the results I won't go into
detail but V you can extort happens if
the matrix is not exactly low rank you
can show similar results so in fact what
I thought about doing was showing those
results for matrix approximation not
completion because our matrix is not
exactly low rank you care about can i
approximate the best ranking
approximation of the matrix using only
power to observe data and I'll show the
results in the context of a different
problem which is column subset selection
so column selection is a very related
problem the goal is again to be able to
you have but usually it's done in the
fully observed setting I'll ask the
question in the partially observed
setting and say if I only observe some
entries of a matrix can I find columns
that give the best rank II approximation
to the matrix
so usually you don't necessarily have to
return like if you only care about
approximation you may not care about am
i finding columns in the matrix but here
that's the question I'll ask we also
have results for the noisy just low-rank
approximation problem but I think this
is slightly different any of those
results for what so why would this be
interesting well in many of these
applications you might care about can I
find the features in these unsupervised
problems that are most representative
like most representative genes or drugs
which users are reflecting the behavior
of most other users or which routers or
notes again this sort of handle most of
the traffic right so in the sense that
specifically which columns are the most
relevant ones can I find some that are
the give me the best drunky
approximation of the matrix so and skip
over this I'll skip over the algorithm
essentially we we took all that I mean
or at least two or three algorithms that
exist for : subset selection and we ask
the question what happens if we do it
for using partially observed data and
you can talk about what happens with
partially observed data and you can talk
about what happens if I actively choose
those and basically the same kind of
idea goes through that if you have
coherent rows or columns then active
sampling can focus on those so I'll just
show this so this is just one algorithm
that adapts the iterative norm sampling
algorithm where you some estimate the
norm of a column and you sample
proportional to that and then you
subtract off that column from the space
of this matrix and then you keep you
basically project all the columns on to
the orthogonal space and then you repeat
this procedure now you can do this with
partially observed data and now we can
adapt how many entries so you initially
only observe some random entries
estimate the column norm sample
according to that and then you can
observe it in full right so same kind of
idea I'll just show that in this case
and one reason I chose to show this
result for matrix approximation is you
actually get a relative error bound so
if your matrix is lower and plus noise
you can actually show you get 1 plus
epsilon approximation in terms of the
best so R is the best residual norm you
can have right so a lot of the noisy
matrix completion results give an
additive error here which means that the
error does not go to 0 if your matrix is
actually low rank whereas here it would
and the complexity I mean somewhere
taking there's not a no gain in fact in
fact we have slightly worse K square
instead of K ok here is acting as a rank
because you want around K approximation
it's slightly worse but actually in
simulations we she see it could be
tightened to n K so it's really in
theory that this will have K square here
and still the main idea is that you can
get this while only needing column space
in conference you know yeah these were
the simulations I'll go over that and we
did this as far as I said many
algorithms norm a sampling leverage core
sampling and basically the main things
are that you can get almost the same
results as the fully observed settings
the only things that are different are
slightly worse factors which are
constants at the eighties for this case
right mostly and you require some
assumptions the incoherent assumptions
but one-sided incoherence not both sides
and what the sample complexity is now
you are able to do this with much fewer
samples than in the fully observing so
the only thing I would say about this I
will just use this as my last slide
which is I think since furniture talked
about active sampling for clustering I
just want to say that again you can see
similar benefits so if you have the
problem of I have n objects and here is
n by n pairwise similarity matrix
between them how many entries do I need
to see to be able to recover this
clustering and you have heterogeneity
either in the form of different size of
clusters or the fact that you have
multi-resolution clusters both cases you
can show that instead of all n square
entries in this matrix you need on the N
log n here and only NK square here if K
is the number of clusters you have but
they are of different sizes this was
done by miral on Yamcha and one well
they show that you can break the root
end barrier for stochastic block models
with that because you can essentially
focus sampling you find the largest
cluster or remove it and then you keep
focusing your sampling on the smaller
ones alright so with that I'll and not
talk about some other things a lot of
people have contributed to this that I
like to acknowledge including Akshay was
here and you know who's with one of the
organizers and our list of relevant
papers
[Applause]
would the incoherence conversion you're
saying for example if I think of it as a
Gaussian graphical model would that vary
with n from a lil' with that literature
but I would say I mean in practice yes
it would vary so ideally you would want
to adapt to all of those conditions
right that's because it's about well
what does this how weak and the KU
partial correlations be they can be very
weak right some some nodes will have
very strong partial correlations with
their neighbors whereas other nodes will
have very weak and you could potentially
try to adapt to that and yeah I can
imagine laying the applications that
would happen
this is possible to mix active and
passive sir it is but most often then
you are back to the at least interior
back to the passive sampling rate that
the improvement you get is not like a
polynomial improvement or exponential
improvement but in practice people do
that all the time actually to safeguard
against things
so one more in the fully of the
offsetting you wouldn't need in current
conditions yes but that's necessary like
you can't show a lower bound I think we
have it in our paper that yeah if you
don't I mean it's just yeah it's a very
simple idea right you need in confidence
otherwise you can't do anything with
partially observed data so remember all
the existing results are for fully
observed right you are given the whole
matrix you just want to approximate it
observe data
thank you
[Applause]